well tell me if this sounds familiar
you've hired someone to remodel your
home and you realize you may have hired
the wrong person question is can you get
out of the contract well eric palacios
has the answer in today's legal minute
sponsored by eric palacios and
associates
hi i'm eric palacios welcome to this
week's legal minute this is a question i
get asked all the time what contracts
can i cancel within three days
number one construction remodeling and
pool contracts the federal trade
commission mandates a three-day right of
rescission for all remodeling and
construction contracts and in nevada
pool contracts apply as well
number two any item over twenty five
dollars purchased by a sales person that
came to your house this is also called
the right of rescission or cooling off
period
now here's the contract you cannot
cancel when you purchase a car many
people mistakenly believe that you have
three days to cancel a purchase of a car
that is not correct the only way you can
return a car is if the dealer has a
written policy to accept refunds or
exchanges don't forget to download the
eric palacio's legal app and we'll see
you next time on the legal minute
and if you'd like more information you
can give eric palacios and associates a
call at that phone number 702-444-7777